Okay, in this chapter you're going
to get a crash course in IndexedDB.
So hold on tight.
Let's get through this as quickly as
possible, and hopefully in one piece.
I'm going to start by going to
the browser and opening idb-test.
This is just a blank
page with a script tag.
This script is in public,
JS, idb-test, index.js.
All it contains at
the moment is an import for
the IDB library we saw before.
So okay then, let's create a database.
We can see from the library's code that
the function signature is .open, and
then the name of the database,
the version,
then a callback to set the database up.
So let's do that.
I'm going to call idb.open,
then name the DB test-db,
version one, and
pass in my setup callback.
This function will be called
if the browser hasn't
heard about this database before.
Or if the version it knows about
is less than this number here.
This function gets a special
upgradeDb parameter
which we used to define the database.
To ensure the database integrity, this
is the only place you can create and
remove objects stores and indexes.
The API for upgradeDb is in the library.
But it's mostly just a mirror of
the real IndexedDB API, except for
a few minor differences
which we'll cover.
The docs tell me createObjectStore
is the same as IDB.
So MDN can give us the full story.
And there's the full detail of the API.
So I'll create an object
store called keyVal.
Because we haven't told it otherwise,
this store has a key that's separate to
the data, which is what we want for
a keyValStore.
I'm going to add some content here, too.
We can see from the library
docs that an object store has
these methods which behave the same
as IDB, except they return a promise.
This is the thing that makes the library
way more usable than plain IDB.
So I want to put an item into the store.
So, let's look at the docs for that.
MDN shows as .put takes an item and
a key, and returns a request.
These request objects are the thing that
makes IDB really difficult to deal with.
So whenever IDB would return a request,
the library returns a promise.
And yes, the signature here is
value key rather than key value.
Which is a real gotcha, but
you'll see why it's like that later on.
In fact, most of the IDB API is stupid,
but for sensible reasons.
So I'm going to put the value world,
and set the key to be hello.
With that,
we've finished setting our database up.
And .open returns a promise that
resolves with a database object.
So we'll store that for later.
We can use that database object to
get and set items in the database.
But for now, if we refresh the page and
run the code.
We can pop over to the resources
panel in dev tools and yeah, and
right click and refresh.
And there we can see our database.
We can see the object store.
And we can see the value inside.
So now,
if I want to read from the database,
I need to create a transaction.
The function to do
this is db.transaction.
Passing any object stores,
I'm going to be using just keyval.
Then I call object store, passing in the
name of the object store I want, keyval.
This seems a bit repetitive but
it's possible to have a transaction
that uses multiple objects stores.
I called .get on the object store,
passing in the key I'm interested in,
hello.
This returns a promise, which resolves
to the value I'm looking for.
Which I'll log.
So over in the browser, if I hit
refresh, there's the console log.
But say, I want to add another
value to the object store.
To do that, I create a transaction
just as I did before but
I specify that I want to
read write this time.
Now, I can get my objects
stores before but
this time,
call .put on on it to set a value.
I'm going to set the key food to be
value bar, .put returns a promise but
this promise doesn't necessarily
mean the operation worked.
As we saw, if the transaction fails.
All the operations
are part of it are undone.
This means that you can do a lot of
work in a transaction and be sure that
it won't be left or accessed in
some kind of half finished state.
Either all happens or
none of it happens.
Transaction.complete is
a promise that fulfills if and
when the transaction completes,
and it rejects if it fails.
Once the transaction completes,
I'm going to logout a success message.
Now I can refresh the browser and
see the console log.
And in the resources panel, there it is.
There's the value we set.
Now, I wanted to talk a bit
more about IDB features, but
it looks like we're getting rudely
interrupted by a certain, Mike Wales.
Mike, what do you want?
>> You've been talking for
quite a while there.
I think it's time we let
the student have a go.
>> Okay.
Yeah.
I think you're right.
Take it away, Mike.